Let's pray together over the holiness that God is teaching us about in His
Word.
Father, you are gracious and holy and patient in all of your
ways. I thank you for the patient teaching and the revealing
of your character.
Thank you, Lord, that you have revealed yourself to us.
You have not hidden yourself, but you have come to us and told us
that you are holy. We praise you, Lord, for what we have
seen, the beauty and the faithfulness and consistency of your character, how
different you are than anything else in all
creation. You are not mixed. You are not like
everything else. You are not weak and dependent and contingent
on everything else. Instead, you are holy and pure and
beautiful and self-sustaining in all of your ways.
I praise you, Lord, for how you have faithfully taught your
people through the centuries. You have taught us about holiness,
and we praise you for that. We rejoice in the assurance that
our God is revealing himself to us in holiness.
Thank you, Lord. So right now, we open our heart and say,
"Teach us. Show us more." Lord, if you'll reveal your
holiness to us, we will rejoice in the holy purity of your
glory. So teach us everything you have, Lord, everything
that you have to teach us about you and everything you can reproduce in our
hearts. Do that, Lord, in this 40 days and on and on for
the rest of our lives. Reveal yourself, show
yourself, reproduce yourselves in us.
We wish to be good learners and good clay on the
wheel of the heavenly potter. Shape us today.
We pray in Jesus' name.
I would encourage you to keep praying and seeking the Lord now, and talk to the
Lord about ways in which he needs to teach you more.
Maybe you feel the gap between what you know and what you
don't know. Let's pray that God would reveal himself in specific ways
and help us to know how to be holy. Let's keep praying.